ayem bien ayem pas ayem bien c'est
derrière bien ayem bien aller
alors l'arrivée d'ayem hier dans tpm
paix a fait énormément parler dès 21h15
quand on a dévoilé que c'était ayem qui
était dans la chouette alors j'aurais
qu'on revienne sur cette arrivée ce
s'est passé donc il hier a été masqué
jusqu'à la fin de l'émission c'est vrai
que jusqu'à la fin de l'émission
même vous ne saviez pas m6 était la
nouvelle chroniqueuse d'ailleurs
personne n'a donné mon nom est personne
n'a su que c'était m est ce que c'est
une bonne idée au passage généré
énormément de réactions sur les réseaux
sociaux
regardez c'était hier vous la connaissez
bien tu leur âme
elle est déjà venue dans l'émission
entre nous deux
la nouvelle chroniqueuse de tpm pays
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il a eu de nombreuses réactions
sur les réseaux sociaux tous vous les
avez lu les réactions iam comment est ce
que vous avez lu les réactions sur la
ligne alun pour être honnête j'ai tout
lu j'ai mis twitter j'ai lu instagram
jésus facebook et c'est marrant parce
que c'était très différent sur twitter y
avait une déferlante de haine et de mai
alors sur twitter c'est vrai qu'il eut
pris sur instagram en revanche c'était
très très positif
donc je peux même moi je vais pas me
positionner on va parler de moi deux
chats mais vraiment il y avait c'était
l'opposé à l'orbiteur c'était méchant et
sur instagram c'était très bienveillant
on va on va vous poser la question vaut
s'y voit la haye m ayem pas ayem déjà et
c'est vrai qu'on va revenir après on
verra on va voir on va voir la jauge ans
pour voir ce que disent les gens en
fonction voilà de ce qui va se passer là
valérie bénaïm vous aime bien ayem bien
ayem bien parce que on a dans cette
émission il regarde et il faut des gens
qui ont une vraie personnalité faut des
gens qui suscite des réactions ce que ce
qui est le cas il faut des gens qui sont
qui sont des grandes gueules qui sont
capables d'être d'intégrer une équipe
parce que c'est une équipe qui est déjà
constitué donc il faut pas être timorés
faut pas être timide où il faut vouloir
il va falloir la ramener je pense
qu'ayem la ram n est qu on a aucun doute
là dessus
c'est une vraie personnalité et et moi
je veux toujours comment dire marketing
les cessations son produit et j'ai
toujours du mal mais quand on tombe sur
quelques heures alors qu'il n'a même pas
encore ouvert la bouche en disant ça
sera forcément pas bien alors vous savez
tpm pc c'est vraiment une famille et on
forme une famille avec les
téléspectateurs c'est vrai que même eux
ils ont l'impression que fait partie de
la famille ont fait partie d'ailleurs
leur famille bon voilà c'est vrai que
tous les soirs on vous retrouve on a
l'impression de vivre avec vous on vous
raconte tout notre histoire voilà vous
suivez toute l'histoire et série que
quand il ya une nouvelle personne qui
arrive dans le jour c'est normal que ça
suscite des réactions
parce que les gens feront peur voilà que
ça déséquilibre la famille bennett trois
lacs salés nature l'émission et qui
tarde donc on peut comprendre que
certaines personnes soient un petit peu
inquiète bien sûr mais souvenez-vous de
la déferlante
idem pour matthieu delormeau sa vraie
déferlante à l'identique way moralisante
été une catastrophe que la téléréalité
envahie c'était pmp que l'émission
allait se dégrader
aujourd'hui c'est une valeur sûre
mathieu de soumission et qu'il est très
fort c'est un vrai personnage donc
pourquoi on laisserait pas sa chance à m
monsieur bien alors isabelle morini-bosc
ayem bien moyenne par ayem bien le
connais pas bien
donc moi je les
mais j'ai toujours entendu parler d'elle
et donc je trouve que c'est un
personnage intéressante donc moi ça
m'intéresse de la connaître mieux même
s'il n'a pas voulu être à côté de moi
c'est pas le cas choisi de faire c'est
bercy a plus vous êtes le taulier donc
où ça se passe très bien et on est ravi
où ça se passe bien mais c'est vous qui
déciderez donc je regarde ou alors on
aura en tout mais non mais non non non
les gens là franchement oui mais c'est
comme un honnête et ils savent
reconnaître un bon chroniqueur d'un
mauvais chroniques et aux maximes guinea
ayem bien je pense que c'est une bonne
chose avec ayem on a une relation
compliquée
visiblement j'ai aurait été maladroit
donc il se braque et je lui dis quelque
chose que l'âme à l'heure où il avait
tenu des propos est comme moi je suis
très très spontanée très authentique
c'est fait la réflexion et ça n'a plus
patiné le plus gentil j'espère que je
vais donc passer par la suite j'ai
l'impression d'arriver dans tpm paix
avec la tp mpf et midi deux soirs plus
souvent j'espère que ça va dissiper nos
mâles nouvelle adresse alors bienvenue
vraiment bon
qu'est ce t'en penses quoi ayem pas je
crois bien m'a dit le pourquoi pascal le
sais moi je suis quelqu'un d'honnête g
de chair pense qu'elle peut pas changer
du jour au lendemain
moi jusqu'à sur nrj 12
j'aimais pas elle vient ici sûreté pmp
c'est très bien moi quand je suis arrivé
ici tu m'as dit t'inquiète pas je sais
ce que je fais j'espère que tu sais ce
que tu fais pour elle aussi et j'ai
confiance
aujourd'hui ce soir vous me demandez si
j'aime bien je me répond j'aime pas
c'est très bien mais maintenant je suis
franc moi je suis d'accord moi
j'aimerais mon papa qui ne sait pas où
ça va vraiment barder allah vous dirais
même bien j'aime bien dans mon bon et
maintenant elle va faire des émissions
et elle va faire ses preuves et elle va
intervenir et comme a dit valérie je
suis même pas légitime mois pour dire si
le géant chimique art comme c'est plus
valérie c'est pas du tout faire les
anciens
moi je vous donne ce que je pense moi
alors quoi tu aimes pas alors dit non
parce que j'aime j'aime pas sur nrj 12
qui pesaient je n'ai pas du tout aimé le
peu de fois que j'ai mis la télé je
l'aimé parce qu'elle sert ensuite j'aime
pas trop le personnage parce que le
personnage est il et il est capricieux
de ce que j'entends mais c'est pareil
c'est ce que j'ai entendu ce qu'on me
ramène des preuves étaient tous tes
capricieuse
tu me fais tes limites chiant et tu le
sais je n'adore s'est bêtement je te dis
après voilà ils disent qu'ils pendant là
je dis ce que je pense et je suis sûr
que tu vas faire des bonnes émissions
aussi parce que tu es une grande gueule
et je sens que ça va marcher c'est ça
mais moi perso j'aime pas j'attends de
voir d'accord très bien passé le dirait
je m'en viens de le dire mon raymond e
durable alors d'avoir testé x un
exercice difficile pour toi c'est
vraiment moi je vais être tout à fait
sincère effectivement je j'exècre la
télé réalité dont tu es issu je la
trouve vide dégradantes vulgaire
avilissante et ravageuse pour la
jeunesse une fois que j'ai dit ça sans
aucun mépris et condescendance mois a
priori en fait j'ai rien contre toi
c'est je suis je suis contente que tu
viens autour de cette table pourquoi
parce qu'on fait la force de tes pmp
pour moi c'est d'être une sorte de
patchwork de sensibilité d'opinion de
cursus dans la vraie vie on se serait
jamais rencontré isabelle raymond kelly
jomby et grâce à cyril effectivement on
se rend compte après moi là haut oui
enfin c'est quand même un bel univers
dans la vraie vie série tout la vitrine
pas sentir à lille je le vois pas dans
la grée tout cette émission nous permet
de nous rencontrer et je pense que ton
regard ta grande gueule ton caractère
peut peut-être moi m'éclairer et on peut
peut-être débat justement quand on parle
des génies du parc comme moi je trouve
absolument insupportable et je pense que
tu met alors à tant de choses quand même
puisque valérie bénaïm pour moi l
excellent parce qu'elle est à la fois
une très très bonne chroniqueuse et une
très bonne animatrice toi tu étais une
très forte animatrice sur nrj 12
donc je sais pas si tu seras une très
forte chroniqueuse mais je te le
souhaite donc bonne chance à la parution
on va j'ai mis ayem pas parce que voilà
parce que c'est pas ça suffit pas
forcément d'être intelligent et des
bobos comme le comme les iem ici il faut
beaucoup bossé et on a ici
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas pour vous mais moi je
suis fan de cela si on bosse pas qu'est
ce qui se passe je me dis nous parce que
moi j'ai moi tes paroles bah voilà
exactement là parce que sous réserve
comme c'est un peu un peu niais je
travaille quand même voilà ils
s'assoient ensemble disons que je suis
là je sais pas si ça bouge mais voilà
l'énergie de bosser autant
et puis après tu es comme on l'a tous
dit était une très bonne animatrice
voilà après donc tu as forcément des
problèmes d'ego j'imagine parce que le
lego va avec avec l'ambition est un
arbre il faut s'intégrer dans une équipe
c'est pas forcément facile voilà même si
ceux de leurs mots et castaldi ils ont
très bien réussi donc je te souhaite
d'avoir la même réussite
et puis comme je sais que dc bat r j'ai
envie en plus de tourner ma pancarte
c'était non à la base mais vient un peu
oui
vous attendez de voir si quelque chose
nous attend évitez de mettre des gens
dans les cases pour une fois un petit
peu du bien parce que je veux dire à un
moment donné à m
elle a tué personne elle a fait du mal à
personne elle insulte personnelle elle
elle fait que du bien autour d'elle
c'est quelqu'un de très gentil
elle a une bonne réputation en interne
et ça c'est important de le savoir
généralement on entend un petit pays ont
dépassé en externe
[Rires]
le bien externes chez nous les gens ont
tendance à trop juger le physique
important de le dire parce que mentir et
et tes coups de gueule et mais c'est ça
qu'on aime aussi ici non moi je pense
que ça mérite pas autant autant de haine
sur internet et personne ne mérite ça
mercenaires et alors c'est quelqu'un
mais sauf que les réseaux sociaux et
twitter précisément sa hystérie ce débat
mais parce que l'adn de la télé réalité
c'est aussi les actions chez ces accords
et tuera il est bien celui de la donc en
fait donc et malgré l'âge buzz peut pas
on peut pas critiquer quelque chose
bah oui a fait mine de rien ayem est
tout exister mais on a regardé c'est
beaucoup de haine pour oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai que sur les réseaux sociaux
pour ça a été vraiment un déferlement
après ayem est ce que ça t'a touché ce
que tu lis des sur twitter ou pas du
tout tu t'es dit non je vais prouver aux
gens que j'ai ma place
alors ne point être très
transparent et je tiens à remercier
quand même kelly et de personnes qui ont
relevé ça parce que on connaît en off et
pas forcément à l'antenne ça peut être
parfois différents j'ai lu des choses
sur twitter qui sont complètement à
l'opposé de ce que j'ai pu lire sur
instagram sur instagram j'ai lu plein de
beaux messages j'ai posté une photo
hier où j'étais complètement détente
avec mon costume de chouettes
donc je pouvais pas prouvé plus comment
dire le côté aux hôtes de jauzion oui
j'ai moi je dérision des visions total
j'étais en costume de chouette avec la
tête comme ça à côté j'ai posté un truc
j'ai remercié civile parce que je tiens
à le remercier gérer mais c'est l'équipe
de tpm paix kim a super bien la cuillère
ça s'est fait rapidement et j'ai eu
plein de beaux messages
après pour ceux qui mettent des mauvais
message je ne peux pas faire l'unanimité
et je ne prétends pas faire l'unanimité
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous pensez
à mener dans touche pas à mon poste
qu'est ce que je pense a mené je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une dans une
ère de la télévision où il en faut pour
tous les goûts
d'accord et je pense que c'est que vous
êtes vous appelez quelque chose en plus
que les autres conducteurs soit vous
êtes une autre personnalité
est ce que vous pensez sa photo de la
capture al-din pareil on a clairement je
prouverai elle a un profil tout à fait
singulier effectivement on a personne
comme elle autour de la table
aujourd'hui par sa jeunesse aussi par
son regard
peut-être sur la télé répond que moi moi
je demande un truc c'est aussi le
legends et yaars est vrai sur twitter
ses mèches mais tu peux pas prendre le
mot le bon et pas prendre le mauvais
bout de tout prendre bien sûr et moi je
demande juste un truc aux gens alors moi
je vais voter que j'aimais pas mais je
vous demande juste aux gens
moi quand je suis arrivé ici au début je
disais à tout le monde se souvenait
qu'est ce que je fous là on voit affecté
chauffeur-livreur voilà voilà
et tout le monde mais j'ai fait
confiance à ses réussites à millas et
qui a quelque chose c'est que tu es tu
vas tu va apporter quelque chose je
pense que c'est la même chose avec ayem
les gens laissez la faire si toi tu as
dit que c'était qu'il fallait qu'elle
vienne je pense que tu as vu quelque
chose et je pense qu'elle va apporter
quelque chose
j'ai surtout vu les yeux de jean michel2
on va pas qu'ils en tirent donc le oui
la belle ayem est ce que toi tu connais
bien les missions
est-ce que tu dois regarder
régulièrement est ce que tu peux pas les
caractéristiques est là moi je connais
très bien les missions et pourrait juste
précédemment sur une émission j'ai
toujours revendiqué et assumé totalement
que civil et sans vouloir faire de la
lèche et je vais le dire en toute
transparence
il a été pour nous un leader que ce soit
pour toutes les personnes qui ont fait
de la télé qui on voulait être à
animateur chroniqueur co animateur on a
tous pris exemple sur cyril parce qu'il
a eu une fulgurance et est un succès
indéniable qu'on a tous vécu hier quant
aux fulgurances de jean-michel non mais
vraiment était un modèle pour nous
pendant des années et ça l'est encore
donc vraiment oui vous bien sûr j'ai
regardé l'émission
et bien sûr je m'en inspire même au
quotidien quand j'étais sur nrj que
j'étais animatrice époux au quotidien on
devait s'inspirer de certaines choses
bien sûr concert en conscience pire et
de cyril et on va pas d'émigrer ça et je
vais pas je vais pas mentir aujourd'hui
là je fais à l'antenne et et je vais
dire les choses en toute transparence on
s'inspirait de cyril de ce qu'ils
faisaient de son contenu de ces
attitudes de 6 rigolade je m'aime je
salue m brune bonnery qui est fébrile
que j'aime beaucoup
voilà qui faisait carrément et je le dis
en toute amitié du copier coller de
cyril parce qu il était inspiré par ses
angles des tous inspirés par cyril donc
j'ai aucun souci à dire ça aliev inspiré
ciel qu'est ce que tu aurais à dire aux
téléspectateurs qui ont voilà pour le
voilà de ton arrivée pour les convaincre
que c'est une bonne idée voilà c'est à
30 secondes sur cette caméra là tu leur
durée quoi je pense que on ne peut pas
faire l'unanimité
je peux comprendre qu'on puisse avoir
des a priori c'est très stressant cette
maison comme fait avoir des a priori sur
moi et je le conçois totalement et j'ai
aucun souci là-dessus c'est normal après
je trouve très dur et très difficile
toute cette déferlante de haine qui peut
y avoir sur les réseaux sociaux sans
même avoir laissé la chance à la
personne de faire ses preuves et je
terminerai avec une phrase je me
rappelle mon père me disait tout le
temps ça quand on plaît à tout le monde
sait qu'on ne plaît à personne et je
crois que c'est sacha guitry qui disait
ça c'est mon papa qui me rappelait tout
le temps cette phrase et je veux juste
te dire un truc sic bas laissez moi
faire mes preuves et puis après on
jugera c'est bien sacha guitry ça il me
semble c'est ça aussi c'est une très
belle chose sachez que l'achat et sacha
guitry et xoom ont recours ayem moi je
vais vous dire juste pourquoi je pense
que c'est un profil qui n'existaient pas
autour de la table et moi la principale
qualité que je demande un chroniqueur
c'est d'être gentil d'être sympathique
et surtout d'avoir un très bon fond et
dieu tu est une belle personne
ici on voit là on peut dire ce qu'on
veut ici il n'ya que des gentils autour
de la table que ce soit mal érigeons
mikkeli maxime c'est un amour acide
loyer géraldine on parle pas raymond
c'est mon pote depuis des années c'est
son frère
voilà donc c'est vrai une castaldi c'est
un amour de mec et c'est vrai que moi je
ne veux que des gens gentils qui sont là
pour s'amuser et qui ont un bon fond qui
sont pas là pour faire des calculs et
faire des essais pour ça caille m je les
choisis à la base parce que un c'est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de talent qui
avait beaucoup de talent sur nrj 12
2 c'est quelqu'un que je trouve qu'un
très bon fou et qui est une belle
personne voilà tout ça donc je me suis
dit avec salle pour bien s'intégrer dans
l'équipe et c'est un nouveau profil
voilà et 3 je cherchais également
quelqu'un motivé jean michel et je pense
que j'ai trouvée elle répond